JESSIE HOLMES (VOICEOVER):
What doesn't kill
you just makes you stronger.
Good practice, get knocked
down, get right back up again
and get back to work.
[music playing]
JESSIE HOLMES: Gee,
gee, gee, gee, gee.
Just got the dogs
out for a good run.
I'm about to start
working on my cabin.
It's kind of been getting
put off a long time.
Had a lot of other
stuff on the plate,
but the tent's kind of becoming
undesirable to live in,
and winter is
extremely set in here.
Winter's long, but
the daylight's short.
And it's been some 20,
25 below temperatures,
and now the temperatures
are really starting to drop.
Nothing like some deep,
cold to get some urgency.
Started this cabin, you know,
before the snow started flying.
I've got everything sealed in.
I got a solid roof on it,
solid foundation, solid walls,
but what I need to do right
now is get the roof insulated.
The daylight's about to be gone.
Limited daylight is
about four hours.
If I work four hours a day,
nothing's going to get done.
So I mean, I could be cutting
wood at 3:00 in the morning,
running dogs 3:00
in the morning,
building the cabin at 3:00 in
the morning, whatever it takes.
You getting this cabin
bill just in time,
cold's really starting
to move in here.
Got the first sheet cut here.
This is one of those things
it would be real nice to have
a second hand with, but this is
where years of handling plywood
comes into play.
This is going to be the
part that's not very fun.
Thank God I got some
purchase on that one.
Whenever I was 20 years
old living in a tent,
all winter was nothing.
But I'm not 20
years old anymore.
I don't recover.
I don't bounce back as quick.
A person needs to feel human.
They need a place
to have their own,
be dry, be warm, keep all
their most important things out
of the weather.
It feels good to get
some momentum back
into this project.
The hardest thing is to
get going, sometimes.
If you're going to be efficient
and effective out here,
you have to figure
out ways of killing
two birds with one stone.
You've got to think
multi-dimensional.
OK, I got most of my
plywood up on the ceiling.
This area I need to leave open,
because I'm going to start
setting my stove up here.
This is kind of
the exciting part.
I'm really looking forward
to getting this wood
stove in here,
because then I can
get myself a source of heat.
I mean, I've been living
in a tent all winter.
I'm out here working in the cold
all night because I want to get
this done, get this cabin
good enough that I can start
moving my stuff in it tonight.